JOEY: WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW."
IN 24 HOURS KIDS WILL BE HEADED
OUT IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
DRESSED IN THE PERFECT COSTUME
FOR TRICK-OR-TREAT.
BUT ACCORDING TO SEVERAL
COLLEGES DWRETION UP IS
TERRIBLE.
IT'S CALLED CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION.
THE UNIVERSITY OF WISCONSIN
MADISON PROMOTING HALLOWEEN
CULTURAL AWARENESS.
UNIVERSITIES ARE USING HALLOWEEN
TO GIVE TIPS ON HOW NOT TO
OFFEND PEOPLE.
THE SPIRIT OF HALLOWEEN MEME
TEMP PLATE IS GOING VIRAL.
THE 30-MINUTE PHONE CALL.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN A 15 MINUTE
CALL.
FIRST WE HAVE THE BERNIE SANDERS
CASUAL.
IT COMES WITH A FOLDING CHAIR,
THE MITTENS AND ALL OF THAT.
DAVID: THE MASK.
JOEY: I HAVE HIM IN MY GROUP
HUNTING PICTURE.
THEN WE HAVE THE SPIRIT
HALLOWEEN STORE ITSELF.
FOR ANY ABANDONED BUILDING THAT
PROBABLY USED TO BE A
BLOCKBUSTER OR KMART THAT TAKES
YOUR HOPES AND DREAMS.
BUT THIS IS THE ONE I REALLY
LIKE.
THIS ONE WILL BE PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IT WILL SHOW PRESIDENT TRUMP IT
SAYS THE GREATEST PRESIDENT OF
ALL TIME LABELED PRESIDENT
TRUMP, LET'S JUXTAPOSE THIS WITH
SOMETHING ACTUALLY FOR SALE.
THIS WILL BE VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
>> IT'S ALSO ON SALE.
I GUESS NOBODY WANTED TO BUY
THEM.
>> DESPITE INFLATION WERE
ACTUALLY ON SALE.
DAVID: IT'S CALLED GETTING LESS
VALUE FOR YOUR VOTE.
I HAVE BEEN TO SPIRIT HALLOWEEN.
THIS IS -- THIS IS CAPITALISM.
BERNIE SANDERS THE COMMUNIST.
THEY HAVE PER IT HALLOWEEN.
THEY ARE SELLING COSTUMES AND
CULTURAL A -- APPROPRIATENESS.
HALLOWEEN IS SOMETHING YOU CAN'T
BE IN YOUR DAILY LIFE AND GOING
OUT AND HAVE FUN BEING IT.
UP UNTIL THRICE WOKE ACTIVISTS,
NOBODY CARED.
FRANKLY I HAVE APPROPRIATED JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING OUT THERE.
ENOUGH.
I LOVE IT.
IT'S CAPITALISM.
JOEY: WE JUST SAW A PICTURE OF
YOU ON ONE OF YOURS.
DAVID: I WAS KING TUT ON ONE OF
THEM.
LARA: I THINK IMITATION IS THE
HIGHEST FORM OF FLATTERY.
I WILL THROW IT OUT THERE IF
ANYBODY WANTS TO LARA TRUMP FOR
HALLOWEEN.
YOU CAN DO IT.
MY SON WAS A LIZARD THOUGH HE
LOOKS LIKE A DINOSAUR.
WE HAVE A LIZARD IN OUR HOUSE WE
CALL LOUIE LIZARD.
JOEY: I REMEMBER A FEW YEARS AGO
A CAUCASIAN GIRL WENT TO PROM
AND WORE AN ETHNIC SOME PART OF
THE WORLD THAT'S NOT AMERICA,
AND PEOPLE GOT MAD AT HER.
SHE SAID WHAT ARE YOU TALK
ABOUT?
I THOUGHT IT WAS THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL THING I HAVE EVER
SEEN.
WHEN DO WE GO FROM CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION TO HONORING
SOMETHING.
LARRY: MY DAUGHTER IS COUNTING
DOWN TO HALLOWEEN.
SHE AND HER FRIENDS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE GOT HERE.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE A FUN
HOLIDAY.
IMITATING SOMEONE IS THE HIGHEST
FORM OF FLATTERY.
HERE IS A PICTURE OF ME AND MY
DAUGHTER.
SHE WAS DOROTHY.
I WAS "ALICE IN WONDERLAND."
IT'S SO FUN TO GO OUT ON
HALLOWEEN AND SEE WHAT PEOPLE
ARE DRESSED UP AS.
DAVID: THERE IS ANOTHER CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION.
REMEMBER NANCY PELOSI AND THE
KENDI CLOTH?
>> EVEN SHE WAS TRYING TO.
BUT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HALLOWEEN HERE.
YOU ARE DRESSING UP.
THERE IS A LIGHTHEARTEDNESS TO
IT.
LARA: DEMOCRATS SUCK THE JOY IN
LIFE OUT OF EVERYTHING.
JOEY: I AM A FAN OF THE PUNT.
SO WHEN I DRESS UP LIKE BRET
CALF KNEW THANK YOU.
I HAVE GOT BACON AND WHISKEY.
I WAS GARTH VADER.
AND WE CROSSED UNIVERSES WITH
WONDER WOMAN A